is moon knights just marvel's version of
dc's batman no not at all what then
makes them different and distinct origin
story powers intellect let's take a look
at all that and more
everyone knows the story of batman's
family bruce wayne an only child grew up
as the heir to the billion dollar wayne
enterprises his parents martha and
thomas were wealthy socialites and
philanthropists dedicated to using their
money to improve lives in gotham city
one night the waynes took their son to a
show but they were accosted by a thug in
the alley after leaving the mugging went
awry and both of bruce's parents were
killed moon knight's family history
could hardly be more different from
batman's young mark spector grew up in
chicago with his father elias and
younger brother randall elias was a
rabbi who escaped the nazis to make a
new life for himself in america he
encouraged his boys to avoid violence in
any conflict elias died when mark was
still a young man but mark's brother
randall remained a big part of his life
and eventually became the super villain
shadow knight tormenting his older
brother whenever possible
after the death of his parents bruce
wayne threw an oath to rid gotham city
of his criminal under belly he dedicated
his life to training for that exact
purpose his years of training took him
around the world as he worked to become
an expert in every discipline that a
master crime fighter might require
perhaps most importantly he trained in
martial arts and as a ninja learning how
to use stealth and darkness to his
advantage mark spector's superhero
training came via less virtuous
motivations early in his life mark
became a boxer despite his father's
insistence on a life of non-violence
after becoming estranged from his father
mark enlisted with the marines and
gained some true military expertise
after that he worked for a time as a cia
agent before going his own way and
becoming a mercenary for hire moon
knight is perfectly accustomed to brutal
fights and making difficult decisions
when battling his enemies because mark
was doing just that long before he
became a hero
one of batman's defining features is his
lack of powers anyone can be batman
provided they have a lifetime's worth of
combat and tactical training as well as
billions of dollars at their disposal
batman may not be a regular person but
he is more grounded than many of the
gods and speedsters that populate dc's
universe batman uses his intelligence
and gadgets to overcome the gap between
himself and some of his friends and foes
what are your superpowers again
i'm rich
by contrast moonlight actually does have
some special abilities in addition to
the increased physical prowess he gains
from years of mercenary work his
relationship with khanshu gives him
access to the supernatural
sometimes he receives dreams of the
future from the deity at other times
moonlight has increased strength
depending on the phase of the moon
despite his occasional burst of
god-powered abilities moon knight tends
to rely on his human strengths and
personal training more than anything
else that comes in handy for him because
moonlight's fractured personality
sometimes leaves him without the
knowledge he has any powers at all
when it comes to the origins of their
costumed identities batman and moonlight
couldn't be more different bruce wayne
trained his entire life to become a
crime fighter on the streets of gotham
when he returned to the city as an adult
he knew that he needed to take on a
persona that would strike fear into the
hearts of criminals drawing got his own
fear of bats as a child bruce created
the mythical figure of batman for that
exact purpose moon knight on the other
hand never really intended to become a
superhero at a young age mark spector
was chosen by the egyptian god of the
moon conscious to become his
representative on earth that first
contact with konshu may have been the
cause of mark's disassociative identity
disorder but it wasn't the moment that
mark became moon knight years later mark
was working as a mercenary in egypt when
he was betrayed and left for dead by his
employer bushman
khonshu revived mark and conscripted him
as his agent on earth mark returned to
new york city and took on the identity
of moon knights to carry out khan shu's
will
batman and moon knights have vastly
different relationships with their alter
egos bruce wayne created batman as a
symbol that would allow him to fight
crime in gotham city more effectively
than law enforcement could over the
years however bruce came to identify
more with his life as batman than his
life as a billionaire mr wayne bruce has
struggled to define himself within two
very different lives has been the
subject of some great batman storylines
like ego a psychotic slide into the
heart of darkness if bruce thinks he has
it bad he could really use a
conversation with moon knight mark
spector developed associative identity
disorder when he was very young his two
primary alters are stephen grant who
becomes a self-made millionaire when
mark as an adult and jake luckily who
spends his time working as a cab driver
other personalities occasionally bubble
to the surface and sometimes mark
suffers a breakdown that causes him to
forget his identity entirely for a time
why did you call me mark
few superheroes brain power can stand up
to batman's intelligence he's then the
title world's greatest detective and
it's frequently batman's careful
planning and detective skills that help
him get out of a sticky situation batman
isn't just able to think his way through
criminal investigations he's also more
than capable of designing all sorts of
high-tech gadgetry that aids him in his
crime fighting if any marvel superhero
compares it's tony stark who also builds
his own technology and tends to think
his way out of problems moon knight is
by no means unintelligent but he doesn't
have the same level of thoughtfulness
that batman so often relies on mark
spector has the street smarts of someone
who's been in and out of every kind of
combat situation imaginable all of his
other personalities are equally crafty
but none of them are going to be
designing futuristic tech anytime soon
that said when there's a need for
serious tactical know-how moon knight is
someone that people want to have around
there are also very few superheroes as
wealthy as batman wayne enterprises as a
multi-billion dollar company with
interest in dozens of different
industries of course bruce wayne
inherited all that wealth in fact he has
little to do with the company's
day-to-day operations but he's invested
in making sure wayne enterprises is
properly managed after all without the
company he'd find it much harder to keep
up his work as batman mark spector grew
up in a working class family in chicago
his mercenary days sustained him but
mark wasn't involved in that work for
the money once he became moon knight he
was more interested in making sure he
had funds for equipment luckily mark's
alter stephen grant is a capable
businessman who earned moonlight
millions of dollars unfortunately due to
various supernatural catastrophes and
mental breakdowns holding on to that
money has never been particularly easy
for moon knight batman and moon knight
have incredibly different fighting
styles batman prefers to attack from the
shadows he's known for silently taking
out enemies ramping up the tension and
fear for everyone else in the room
waiting to be attacked while he
certainly has some weapons knowledge
batman usually fights with his fists and
takes down bad guys with his superior
hand-to-hand technique and pure strength
moonlight also likes to use fear to his
advantage when fighting baddies but he
prefers to let them see him coming moon
knight's white costume is meant to make
him easily visible so whoever he's
hunting down knows that time is just
about up due to his extensive combat
training moon knight is an expert with
most weapons he can use just about
anything in a fight but fittingly the
fists of khanshu's signature weapons are
special crescent moon-shaped throwing
knives the knives are effective in
combat and leave moon knight's mark on
the scene which helps to boost the
menace of his persona and instill terror
into anyone he faces
no one stays dead in comics any
exceptions to the rule that comes to
mind just haven't been resurrected yet
batman and moon knight both abide by the
rule but their comic book immortality is
also one of their key differences any
time that bruce wayne has died in the
comics there's always been a secret plot
twist that kept him alive for example
after apparently dying in final crisis
it's revealed that he actually became
lost in time until his friends were able
to help bring him back false alarm
are you sure
moonlight on the other hand has died for
real he was originally saved from death
by kanchu and the egyptian god hasn't
been shy about resurrecting him again
moon knight died for a second time in
issue 60 which was released in 1994 and
ended his comic series for a time fans
might have believed his death was
permanent but in 1997 moon knight
returned kicking off the resurrection
war platak moon knight's relationship
with konchu is often strained at best so
there's no guarantee that god will
always be willing to bring the hero back
from the dead however the option is
always on the table
the single biggest difference between
batman and moonlight is their ideas of
morality each hero's morals come from
his background and inform just about
every decision he makes while fighting
crime young bruce wayne saw his parents
gunned down in an alley since then he's
been determined to fight evil but he's
also been committed to not using guns
and not killing his enemies there have
sometimes been exceptions to batman's
rules usually in spin-offs and alternate
realities but for the most part batman's
refusal to kill is a single most
important aspect of his character moon
knight generally has no qualms about
killing though his father always
preached on violence moon knight has
spent his entire life embroiled in one
kind of fight or another as a boxer
marine and mercenary violence was his
trade as the fists of konchu moon knight
has an obligation to strike down evil
wherever he finds it in many ways moon
knight is a more vicious and brutal
fighter than batman because he doesn't
even try to hold back his rage most of
the time moonlight is openly trying to
kill his opponent don't let white
clothes fool you if anything moon knight
is an even darker character than the
dark knight himself
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one